all agents we have an inbound blizzard
warning we have to get the cure and get
out before the storm hit
the hunters are a completely different
NPC type that was introduced when the
survival update dropped unfortunately
there isn't really that much covered in
game through the recordings and echoes
and even the New York collapse book only
briefly mentioned something that could
be directed towards the hunters so as
far as the official story goes the
identity of the hunters is a mystery but
through the facts we do know about them
there are a number of theories as to who
the hunters are and where they come from
in this video I'm going to run through
some of the more popular theories and
discuss the potential origin and motives
of these agent killing machines for the
purpose of figuring out where they sit
in the overall lore of the division I'll
be talking about the hunters based on
their initial introduction to the game
survival as I believe that the addition
of hunters to the underground legendary
missions and resistance was more of the
challenge of balancing update to these
game modes then a continuation of the
story of course the same could be said
about the initial introduction of the
hunters - but there are just too many
telltale signs and pieces that lineup to
consider these as simply a new NPC added
for greater difficulty with no backstory
firstly let's cover what we do know
about the hunters they use advanced
combat movement and strategies have
stronger weapons and tougher armor than
division agents use shade technology
behave cooperatively target first and
second wave division agents don't attack
civilians collect agent watches
originated in the dark zone based on
this information alone I feel it's
fairly reasonable to state that the
hunters are not affiliated with the
rioters rikers cleaners and even the
alien be as their technology and
training is far superior to anything
these factions offer so of this in mind
let's run over some of the theories that
have come out hunters a former first
wave agents loyal to aaron kena this is
probably one of the most popular
theories out there as we know kena has a
blueprint for the dollar fluke he
obtained it through m posts laboratory
and he also has docked of the tally to
Niko who has knowledge to create a
potential cure so naturally he'd want a
cure to be developed to keep himself and
everyone loyal to him safe the
antivirals even if they're
would be beneficial towards the creation
of the cure so having agents that were
highly skilled and trained to protect
these would be of interest to kena on
top of this if the strategic homeland
division was to obtain the antivirus and
create a cure it would severely reduce
the threat of kinas plan to weaponize
the virus dramatically lowering any
leverage he has so the hunters are
basically there is an elite agent
collecting and stopping anyone from
extracting the antivirals from the dark
zone it's certainly possible and a lot
of things do line up but this theory
doesn't quite sit well with me and I'll
go into that soon but first I'll run
over theory number two it's very similar
to this one but with one very slight
difference hunters of former first-wave
agents not loyal to Aaron kena as we
know when things went from bad to worse
in the dark zone Aaron kena split from
the division and went rogue a number of
first wave agents proceeded to join him
any agents that didn't work illed and
because of this any agents that work
loyal to Aaron kena
cut communications and went into hiding
this cutting of communications was to
stop them from being hunted down but
unfortunately the sort of also cut them
off from the rest of the division - it's
likely that while in hiding they weren't
actually aware of the second wave being
activated so in the second way of agents
show up using shd tech and other
division agent gear they just seen as
another first wave agent fighting for
kina we also need to think about the
mental state of these agents second wave
agents have it tough but the first wave
agents would have had it much worse then
they had the government pull out of the
dark zone leaving them behind and
finally with the likes of kina and his
rogue agents they started turning on
each other this could explain why the
hunters fight with such brutality
they're seeking revenge and why did they
come out of hiding to attack agents
during a blizzard they see the agents
were weakened and struggling to get
extracted so they're using the
opportunity to strike back this theory
feels a lot more plausible than the
previous one as it talks a lot more to
the savage fighting style and trophy
hunting practices of the hunters they're
alone cut off from the outside world and
seeking revenge for Aaron Chema's
betrayal of the government and their
fellow first wave agents but there is
one thing that just doesn't feel right
with these two theories the hunters are
obviously the Knicks tear up from the
Agence their movement fighting styles
armor and even their equipment is of
higher quality and better technology
than the first and second wave agents
they have text specifically for jamming
shd equipment sure having been left to
survive on their own against the weather
and other hostile factions will have
taught them some things and honed in on
a few of their existing talents but it
hasn't been long enough for them to be
able to fight that much more effectively
than the rest of the division agents
we've already faced a couple of keenest
rogue agents scarecrow and Raptor and
the hunters are on a completely
different level now I'm just stating
that they're not first wave agents
I still believe they have something to
do with the shd hunters I Russian agents
I see this one pop up from time to time
the idea behind this one is that while
locked up in the Russian consulate the
telogen n Co contacted the Russian
government and tried to exchange his
knowledge on the virus for an escape out
of the city this was too late as the
Russian consulate was sieged by Aaron
kina and the LMB
and he was kidnapped the Russians
learned of this and retaliated by
sending in a group of highly trained
agents to hunt them down this is why the
hunters are always targeting first and
second wave division agents and hope
that they can extract information on
Aaron kina and his whereabouts these
agents had to specialize in keeping out
of sight and must appear as though
they're not affiliated with Russia to
avoid international conflict between the
two superpower countries I can see why
people have come up with the somewhat
cliche theory but there are a number of
things that just don't really line up in
the turn encode audio logs we're told
about Russia pulling out of New York
pretty heavily following the outbreak
with the fact that a number of the
larger cities and Russia have also been
hit with the virus they're more likely
to be committing all resources to
helping themselves but the Russian
government needs to Niko for his
knowledge on the virus we need to
remember that Amherst went to Russia to
study as Russia is the only other
country that has smallpox samples in
fact he met Tanika in a Russian lab it's
more than likely that Russia already has
their own research on the virus plus we
need to remember that this is a global
epidemic the situation is dire countries
will be focusing on containing and
fixing the problems at home rather than
using precious resources on political
agendas
hunters are the third wave this is the
theory that I find the most probable as
it texts the most boxes and fills the
most in line with the story and it also
acts as a bit of a twist for the future
of the franchise the second wave was
activated with the objective to find out
what happened to the first wave and to
continue with the goal of restoring
order when the second wave learned about
the treason of the first wave the
government was also listening up until
this point the second wave was doing a
good job shutting down the hostile
factions and now the biggest threat that
was rising was the agents themselves we
need to think about it from the
government point of view first wave
agents are sentient they all go mi a
second wave agents get sent in to
investigate they find out that the first
wave agents betray their country and go
rogue under the leadership of one of
their own the risk of the second wave
join in Kita's crew was extremely high
in order to manage this risk they have
or they create a back-up plan the third
wave this wave is equipped with gear and
training that solely focuses on taking
down shd agents to stop it from getting
too far out of hand they release the
hunters whose primary job is to take
down any and all division agents also
the first and second wave agents have
been privy to a lot of information
around the government's failing of their
attempt to contain the outbreak they
forced all of the second to an area of
the city and then gave up and left
leaving agents and thousands of sick to
fend for themselves the hunt is being
sentient to eliminate all division
agents mean that there's no one around
to know it actually happened but then
who removes the hunters I believe that
the hunters are only given enough
information to remove the division
agents from New York City no more no
less
they're simply given the information
that all division agents are traitors
and need to be eliminated this could
also explain why the hunters clicked
agent Watchers 2 when following missing
agent alerts we find a watch at the end
and this supplies a lot of the
information regarding the missing agent
the hunters are collecting these watches
under direction to further assist in
stopping the story from getting out now
in keeping this disaster a secret the
government cannot be seen to be sitting
in troops to eliminate their own this is
why the hunters wear masks so I've seen
they can't be identified and this could
also explain why they kill in such a
brutal manner they want it to appear as
if one of the hostile factions were
responsible in the book Tom Clancy's the
division New York collapse it centered
that there is a division within the
division this could mean many things but
implies that there is more than one
division within this strategic homeland
division it could just be talking about
the first and second wave but it could
also be hinting at the hunters being a
separate faction within the division
suddenly kinas reasons for turning rogue
doesn't look so bad right maybe he saw
this coming after the initial portrayal
of the government when they left the
first wave agents for dead after
withdrawing from the dark zone maybe
this is where the supply drops are
coming from and who they're intended for
these aren't fully explained and even
fail our doesn't fully understand them
apologies that are couldn't bring in any
real hard facts about the story of the
hunters there just isn't anything out
there I believe they've purposely left
the hunters out of the story for now to
give them that mystery but I think we'll
be hearing more about them in division 2
hopefully they'll clear this up for us
this has probably raised more questions
than it answered but it shows the depth
that the division story can go even with
the last theory there are a ton of
questions to be answered but really any
of these are a possibility as we only
have a few clues to go by which of these
do you find most plausible or do you
have a theory of your own anyway
hopefully you've enjoyed this or at the
very least I've got you thinking see you
on the next one
Cheers
you
[Music]